maître Nicole plaide au nom de toutes
les victimes et pour lui l'effet se
résume ainsi quand la bêtise celle des
deux accusés rencontre la chance
c'est-à-dire un incroyable enchaînement
de circonstanceces cela produit le crime
et les vies de réi kulanski et de
nicolados Reiss certes marqué par de
graves carrences affectives et
éducatives ne les excusent en rien les
victimes ont connu de plus grandes
épreuves que à ce petit jeuà nous
gagnons lâche l'avocat quant au fait que
les deux cousins n'ont jamais voulu
semer la mort ça non plus ça ne les
dédouine pas j'ai fait un parallélisme
avec la personne qui alcoolisée prend un
volant le volant d'un véhicule et tue
une famille entière bien sûr elle n'a
pas voulu la mort de la famille entière
mais elle a pris la responsabilité de
d'ingérer de l'alcool et de conduire
donc ils sont intégralement responsables
on n' pas besoin d'être expert pour
savoir que quand on joue avec le feu on
prend des risques énormes et quand ces
risques se concrétisent et bien on doit
en assumer la responsabilité nous
pouvons faire le procès de la bêtise
mais pas celui de la chance pours maîre
Nicole les victimes s'interrogent
toujours sur la configuration des lieux
se posent des questions sur l'isolant
hautement inflammable posé en façade
façade dont le décrochement a attisé le
brziier se désole encore aujourd'hui de
l'absence d'un gardien de nuit en guise
de réponse presque de justification
l'avocat d'Adoma rappelle que l'enquête
n'a pointé aucune défaillance en matière
de sécurité on peut toujours se poser
des questions l'emplacement des
poubelles pourquoi avoir mis ses
poubelles à cet endroit-là euh on vient
nous dire aujourd'hui à postériori le
bon sens aurait voulu qu'on les mettre
ailleurs mais avant personne s'est posé
la question alors que cela cela fait
l'objet d'une demande de permis de
construire avec un plan
avec le produit qui était mis en œuvre
et la ville n'a rien dit la direction du
territoire n'a rien dit les pompiers
n'ont rien dit parce que c'était pas
l'évidence du tout les avocats se sont
ensuite relayés pour évoquer le parcours
et les préjudices des quelques 200
victimes de l'incendie on a jusqu'ici
parler beaucoup des accusés dit une des
avocates maintenant c'est autour de ces
invisibles d'exister et les deux cousins
doivent écouter chaque vie une à
une